Is for the immigrants.
Germany is not our country of origins.
Basically, we are here for a propose.
Some of us are here based on asylum reasons.
Some of us are here based on,
you know, our integration reasons.
Some of us are here based on work.
Some of us are here so,
so many reasons that brought all of us here together.
So for us to succeed has asylum seekers.
For us to succeed has job seekers.
For us to succeed has.
Whatsoever in this country,
the most important thing,
the key, is inclusion. Inclusion.
How can we include,
involve, socialize ourselves in this society,
in this society,
in the German society,
in regions, states,
villages where we are living,
has immigrants.
So that's why I think, uh,
is important.
Is a necessity for us to also talk about integration
of immigrants in Germany.
Well, integration have different branches. I,
I always said that
for a migrant or immigrant to get integrated,
there are different,
different branches of integration,
you know? Of course.
And another important thing is
in integration, some,
some, some are very slow in integration. Inclusion.
Some are very,
very slow, but then some are equally very fast.
But here we are going to discuss,
we are going to talk about
how can we help each other to be integrated,
you know, what are some of the things that we can do to.
To get integrated here in Germany?
What are some of the best methods?
Of integration in Germany,
of course, when we talk about best matters,
best possibilities,
you know, fastest ways to get integrated,
to get inclusive, to.
To be, you know,
to get into the system here, I think.